The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're pretty much
ready to get started.
Let's settle down and take a
look at the clicker question.
So take 10 more seconds.
Very good.
Most people had this right, and
the trick here is just to
think about the sign of delta
g, whether it's negative and
positive, and think about the
equation and the influence of
temperature on that equation.
So whether it's going to make
delta s a bigger factor or a
smaller factor and how
that will play out.
So you can look at the equation
and figure out what
the signs have to be and then
the influence of temperature.
All right, so let's move to the
first slide that I have
today, which is welcome to the
middle of the semester.
So I'm Kathy Drennan and this
is lecture 19 of 36, which
means that you are halfway
through the course.
And so what you heard on Monday
before the exam was
about thermodynamics, and if you
don't have all your delta
g's and delta h's and if you
don't have entropy full in
mind, that's OK, we are not
really leaving thermodynamics,
we're going into chemical
equilibrium, which is all
about thermodynamics.
So you're going to hear a lot
more about delta g, delta h,
temperature, and about our
friend, entropy as we go along
in the second half.
So it's the middle
of the semester.
That means that you've had two
of the sort of four hour exams
-- remember the fourth hour exam
is actually combined with
the final exam.
So the final exam is 200 points
of cumulative material,
and 100 points of new material,
so you've done two
now of those four sort
of hour exams.
Just to remind you of some of
the topics you have seen and
the topics coming ahead, this is
on the syllabus, and we're
actually where we're supposed
to be on the syllabus, so if
you want to take a look at that
ever to see where we're
going, we're actually
on track.
So the first half of the course
are a lot of basic
principles, and we're moving
today into chemical
equilibrium, so a lot
more delta g's,
delta h's coming on.
And then we're going to move
into acid base, which is acid
base equilibrium.
So we're not going to be
leaving equilibrium or
thermodynamics.
Then we're going to go into
oxidation reduction, which is
also about equilibrium, and then
transition metals, and
end with kenetics.
And so, these altogether
represent the fundamentals
needed for the study of
biochemistry, organic
chemistry, any kind of
chemistry, biology, the life
sciences, many things -- so
you're getting all the
fundamental principles of
chemistry in this class.
So along those lines, I just
thought I would share
something that happened to me on
Wednesday when I was riding
the T, the Silver Line,
in particular.
So I don't know if any of you
have had this kind of
experience yet where you're on
public transportation and
someone next to you says, "So,
are you a student?" Maybe you
have a notebook out or a
book out or something.
And you say, "Yes," and they
said, "Oh, what are you
studying?" And then you say
"Well, you know, chemistry,
math, physics." And they're like
"Oh." And then they go
busy themselves doing
something else.
Or they tell you "I didn't
really like those subjects in
school." And then they
stop talking to you.
So how many people have had that
experience so far, that
you scare the person next to
you by what you study?
OK, a few people.
If I ask that question four
years from now, I think it'll
be like half the class,
eight years from
now it'll be everybody.
So this is kind of common.
But what happened to me on the
Silver Line was actually
pretty exciting, because
I've had that other
experience many times.
So, I was wearing my keys
around my neck, because
women's professional clothes, no
pockets, with a little MIT
cord, and the person next to
be on the Silver Line said
"So, do you go to the Georgia
Tech of the east?" And I said
"Well, I am a professor at MIT."
And he said "Well, I'm a
mechanical engineer and I went
to Georgia Tech." And so he
said, "So, what do you teach?"
I said, "Chemistry." And he
said, "Chemistry --
I really wish I had paid more
attention in chemistry." I
said, "Well, what do you do
now?" And he said "Well, I
work for the army, and I'm
part of a team that has
mechanical engineers, electrical
engineers, and
chemists, and we're trying to
figure out ways to detect
explosives." So I said, "Oh,
well have you heard of the
head of the Chemistry Department
at MIT, Tim Swager
who works in the area, and he
said, "Yes," he knew the name.
And so he said that one of his
porblems on the team, and in
talking to the chemist, his
chemistry language is not
really good enough, and so he
was really struggling, and
that the best results of this
team effort would be if
everyone could really
talk to each other.
So he wished that he had paid
more attention in his
chemistry class.
And so I, of course, my
connection with chemistry was
by wanting to understand
biology, but for everyone it
might be a little
bit different.
So, as I mentioned in the
beginning of the class, one
challenge that you have this
semester is figure out what
your connection to
chemistry is.
What are you going to
use chemistry for?
How does this fit into
what you want to do?
And maybe for some of you,
you're not going
to know that yet.
Hopefully it won't take till you
have a job doing something
to realize that you're lacking
something in your education.
And so, probably if you stay
in science and engineering,
need chemistry, good to
learn it all now.
And from exam 2, we see that
you are learning it now and
that's really great.
So, some day maybe someone in
this room will be involved in
national security, and if you're
not a chemist, you'll
be able to talk to the chemists
and make really good
progress toward that work.
So, chemistry -- it's important
in medicine,
national security, the economy,
energy initiatives, a
lot of the big things
going on now.
It's a fundamental, and you will
get in this course, the
fundamentals.
So if you have any good tea or
bus or airplane conversations,
let me know --
I'll catalog those for
future reference.
It's always a touch of how what
we do here connects with
the real world.
All right, so we're not going
far from thermodynamics, we're
going into chemical
equilibrium.
And we're going to be talking
a lot about delta g.
So if delta g is not your friend
yet, don't worry, you
can still bond with delta g.
All right, so chemical
reactions, chemical reactions
can go into a state
of equilibrium.
And it's a dynamic equilibrium,
the reaction is
still happening, but if a
reaction is an equilibrium,
the rate of the forward reaction
will equal the rate
of the reverse reaction, so
there'll be no net change in
composition.
So let's take a look
at an example.
So let's look at a reaction in
which we have nitrogen gas,
and we have hydrogen
gas, and they are
reacting to form ammonia.
Suppose we just start with
nitrogen gas and hydrogen gas
and we don't have any
ammonia left.
So if we consider concentrations
versus time.
So say we start with, we have
some nitrogen gas, some
concentration of nitrogen gas.
As it reacts with hydrogen,
the concentration will
decrease and then level off.
We'll start with some amount
of hydrogen gas, and its
concentration will also decrease
and level off.
And in the beginning we won't
have any of the product, any
of the ammonia, so its
concentration will increase
and then level off.
So when these reactions level
off, you're reaching
equilibrium.
The reaction is still happening,
but the rate of the
forward reaction is equal to
the rate of the reverse
reaction, so there's
no net change.
So the concentrations are
staying the same, but there's
still -- the reaction is
still going forward.
So let's think about the case
when we have pure reactants
when we haven't formed enough
products yet to reach
equilibrium.
So if we have pure reactants,
the reaction is going to be
spontaneous in the forward
direction.
So we'll have a reaction
that is spontaneous
in the forward direction.
And what will that mean about
our friend delta g?
Is it going to be greater
or less than zero?
So it'll be less than zero --
so delta g or the forward
reaction will be
less than zero.
So when delta g is negative, the
reaction is spontaneous in
the forward direction.
So what about when you have
pure products, then the
reaction should be spontaneous
in the reverse direction.
So you have spontaneous in the
reverse direction, and what
does that mean about the
sign of delta g?
Greater or less than zero?
Greater, so it'll be positive.
So, we can think about that
in terms of a plot.
We can think about free
energy versus the
progress of the reaction.
So, the progress of the
reaction is going this
direction as you go along.
So in the beginning if you have
pure reactants, delta g
is going to be less than zero.
And you're going to proceed
along in the forward direction
spontaneously.
If, on the other hand you have
pure products, delta g will be
positive, so you'll be
spontaneous in the reverse
direction, and the reaction
will go in the reverse
direction until what happens?
Till you reach equilibrium.
And what would delta g
be at equilibrium?
Zero.
So you see, there is a great
relationship between delta g
and equilibrium, so we have
not left delta g behind.
So, delta g is going to change
as the components of the
reaction change.
As you have more products or
more reactants, you're going
to have a different delta g.
So let's look at
some equations.
So delta g is the change in free
energy, the difference in
free energy, at some point in
the reaction at any time with
amount of composition.
We also have delta g nought,
which talks about delta g
under particular conditions, so
it's sort of the standard
free energy.
We have a term called q, which
is the reaction quotient,
which tells you about products
and reactants.
We have our friend r, which is
the gas constant, and this
depends on temperature.
So temperature is a term
involved here.
So the delta g at any point in
the reaction is going to
depend on the delta g nought
for that reaction, and the
reaction quotient, products
and reactants, and we'll
define this in a minute, and
then the temperature as well.
So we need to know more about
what q is, what this reaction
quotient is.
So this slide looks a little bit
scary, but it's going to
be fine, because a lot of the
terms are going to cancel out.
So we're going to talk about q,
this reaction quotient, and
we're going to have different
types of problems -- some
where we're talking about
gases, and others we're
talking about solutions.
So you can see two different
kinds of q's, one that depends
on partial pressure of the gas,
and another that depends
on concentration.
So here is our equation again
that we just saw -- delta g
equals delta g nought plus r t
natural log of q, and here
we've expanded the term for q.
So p to the sub x is the
partial pressure of a
particular gas, and so in this
equation, we have a plus b
going to c plus d, the top of
the line or the products.
So we have the partial pressure
of gas c, and this is
over a reference, partial
pressure, raised to the power
c, the coefficient, and then
also we have d, the partial
pressure of gas d, over a
reference raised to the
small letter d.
On the bottom of the terms for
the reactants, partial
pressure of gas a over a
reference raised to the
coefficient a, partial pressure
of gas b over the
reference raised to
the coefficient b.
Now what's great is that the
partial pressure is one bar,
and so that basically cancels
out as far as we're concerned.
And so the term for q
is much simplified.
You won't see problems that have
the reference in them, so
you can just think about
q in terms of
products over reactants.
And you just have to remember
that the coefficients in the
reactions do matter.
If you're talking about
solutions, the only difference
is that we'll be talking about
molar, so we have one molar,
so the reference term here
also cancels out.
When you see something in
brackets, like c in brackets,
here that telling you it's
a concentration term.
So here, q is the concentration
of c raised to
its coefficiency.
The concentration of
d raised to its
coefficient d over reactants.
Concentration of a to
a, concentration
of b raised to b.
So the thing in x indicates
it's a concentration term.
So q is just products over
reactants, considering the
stoichiometry of the particular
reaction.
So what about the equilibrium
constant k?
So at equilibrium you told me
that delta g equals zero, and
at equilibrium q, the reaction
quotient equals k, the
equilibrium constant.
So we can consider that in terms
of this expression, if
we're talking about this
expression at equilibrium,
delta g is going
to equal zero.
And so, we just set this whole
term equal to zero.
We can rearrange the equation
bringing delta g nought to the
other side.
And so we have delta g at
nought equals minus r t
natural log of K, because at
equilibrium, k is equal to q.
So now we have another term to
solve for delta g, and an
equation that relates delta
g nought to be equilibrium
constant k.
So k, the equilibrium's constant
has the same form as
q, but we're only talking about
the concentrations or
the partial pressures of
things at equilibrium.
So it's the same, it's product
over reactants, same
expressions as q, but in the
corner you say at equilibrium.
So you're only talking about the
concentrations of things
at equilibrium if you're
solving for k.
If you're solving for q, it's
the concentration or the
partial pressure at any time in
that particular reaction.
Important thing, products
over reactants.
All right, so, we can rewrite
the equation one more way.
So I just told you that delta g
nought is equal to minus r t
natural log of K. So we can
substitute into the expression
minus r t natural log
of k, and now we can
rearrange this equation.
And so, if we rearrange it, we
have delta g, the delta g at
any particular point in the
reaction equals r t natural
log of q over k.
And this equation is helpful for
people if they're thinking
about what is the equilibrium
constant, what concentrations
do I have now -- we're not
at equilibrium, what
concentrations do I have now,
what is q now in the reaction,
how does that compare to k?
And when you know what those
values are, you'll know
something about the direction of
the reaction because you'll
know if delta g is positive
or negative.
It'll to be spontaneous in the
forward direction or in the
reverse direction.
So this is a handy equation
for thinking about the
relationship q k delta g.
So let's think about that
relationship for a minute.
If q is less than k, what
is the sign of delta g?
So it would be negative, which
means the forward direction of
the reaction will occur.
So if you think about it, you
can think about in terms of
products and reactants.
So at equilibrium then, if q is
less than k at equilibrium,
there are more products than
there are right now, so you
need to make more products.
So you would have delta g would
be negative, you'll see
that mathematically, and you can
think about it in terms of
whether you're going
to make more
products or less products.
If q is greater than
k, what is delta g?
So it would be positive
and the reverse
direction would occur.
So you think that at q, if it's
larger than k, it has
more products in its terms, and
at equilibrium there are
less products, so you need to
go in a direction that will
get rid of some of those
products so you'll reach
equilibrium again.
So this equation is very helpful
in thinking about the
direction of the reaction --
which direction will it be
spontaneous.
So let's look at an example.
K is given in this example, and
then we have a bunch of
partial pressures.
And we're asked which
direction the
reaction will go.
So what do I need to do to
answer this question, what do
I need to calculate?
So if I'm given k, and a bunch
of partial pressures, what do
I first need to calculate?
Q, right.
So let's calculate q.
So q, we're going to talk about
products over reactants,
so we're going to talk about
be partial pressure of the
ammonia, and there are two
of them being formed.
Our reactants, we want to talk
about the partial pressure of
the nitrogen, and the partial
pressure of the hydrogen gas,
and again include the
stoichiometry, so we have
three there.
So now I can plug in my values,
so I'm told I have 1 .
1 bar, and down here I have 5 .
5 and 2 .
2 to the 3, again, considering
the stoichiometry.
And if you do the math,
you get 2 .
1 times 10 to the minus 2.
That's your q value.
Now given your k value, which
the problem states, and this q
value, let's do a clicker
question, tell me which
direction the reaction
will go.
All right, 10 seconds.
So, 77%, pretty good.
So, q is greater than k here.
And if q is greater than
k, what will be
true about delta g?
I have another clicker question
for that -- yell out
the answer.
What is it?
Positive, right.
So you're going to shift towards
reactants, so you're
going to go in the reverse
direction.
So you think about whether there
are more products or
less products at equilibrium,
and so there are more
products, so we have to think
about which direction it'll
go, and here, ammonium will
dissociate until equilibrium
is reached again.
OK.
So let's think more about what
k is going to tell us.
So k tells us about the mixture
of products and
reactants at equilibrium,
whether we can expect low or
high concentration of reactants
at equilibrium.
So let's look at another
example.
So when you have k that's
greater than one, so more
products than reactants at
equilibrium, you can think
about this in terms of higher
products at equilibrium.
When you have k less than
one, we're going
to have lower products.
So again, think about k in
terms of products over
reactants at equilibrium.
So if k is greater than
one, there are more
products than reactants.
If it's less than one,
there will be less
reactants than products.
So let's look at an
example of that.
Let's look at when k is
greater than one.
And I have the equation
up there and I'll
write it here as well.
So we have 2 n o 2, and two
double arrows, and n 2 o 4.
So we have a k value
here of 6 .
84, so that's greater
than one value.
So let's think about
this reaction.
So over here instead of
concentration, we're going to
talk about partial pressure
because we're talking about
gas, and we have time.
So initially we have
a reactant.
And the reactant starts at
some concentration and
decreases and then reaches a
straight line, so reaches
equilibrium.
So we have our reactant here.
Originally we have no product,
and so product is going to go
up and be formed and then it's
going to level off as you
reach equilibrium.
So initially, what is
true about q and k?
So with no products, what
is true about q and k?
Q is less than k.
And so what's true
about delta g?
Less than zero, it'll be
negative, so it'll be
spontaneous in the forward
direction.
So you're going to be
spontaneous in the forward
direction and you're going
to make your product.
So now let's calculate what the
concentrations are going
to be at equilibrium.
So initially, so you have your
initial pressure for the
reaction, 2 n o 2 going to
n 2 o 2, and our initial
concentrations are
given as one bar,
and we have no product.
Now we talk about the change as
we go toward equilibrium,
how much does the
reactant change?
What do I write here?
What change?
Minus x minus something x?
Minus 2 x.
So again, we're considering
the stoichiometry,
and what's over here?
So just plus x, and then at
equilibrium we now have 1
minus 2 x and x.
So we're talking about
equilibrium concentrations, so
we're talking about
k, so k equals 6 .
84, which is going to be equal
to the partial pressure of the
product over the partial
pressure of
the reactant squared.
So it's going to be equal to
x over 1 minus 2 x squared.
So x, if you calculate it out,
should equal point 381 bar.
And then if we do 1 minus 2
times 0.381 bar, we get 0 .
238 bar.
So if we go back over here, our
products at equilibrium --
oh, I guess I should write what
-- so x is our product
and this is our reactant.
So the product we have 0 .
381, and our reactant
at equilibrium is
going to be 0.238 bar.
So we have more product than
reactant at equilibrium, which
is consistent with the value of
k being greater than one.
So, when you know something
about the equilibrium
constant, you know something
about the reaction and whether
you would expect more products
or reactants at equilibrium.
So again, you can think about
this in terms of q and k.
All right, so now we are
going to go toward our
next clicker question.
So if we can rewrite the
expression for delta g equals
minus r t natural log of k, and
express it in terms of k,
and now we can think about
then what is that
relationship.
If you have a large value for
k, what do you expect to be
true about delta g nought?
All right, let's give
that 10 seconds.
OK, why don't you discuss for
a minute with your friends
whether you agree with
that 78% or not.
All right, now we're going to
re-poll, so click in again.
Now give the right answer.
Interesting.
It actually usually goes the
other direction, that after
there's a discussion, more
people come to the same
conclusion.
So I guess it's a matter of if
the professor asks that, you
assume that that must have
been the wrong answer.
Was that people's logic?
So what are the points of doing
this, and we're going to
actually do this kind of thing
a few more times in class, is
that collectively, and I was
actually just at an education
meeting about science down at
the Howard Hughes Medical
Institute, that statistics show
that if you have a group
where everyone in the group
has the wrong answer and
they're allowed to discuss it,
there's a good chance they'll
come up with the right answer.
So that it's not just about one
person in the group having
the right answer, convincing
everyone else that they're
right, that the act of
discussing often
leads to new answers.
So now that you know that it's
not a trick on my part to tell
you you got it wrong, we'll see
next time whether this, in
fact, holds, that the act of
discussing helps give the
right answer.
Anyway, so if k is large, it
is true that delta g nought
would tend to be negative and
more -- it would be negative
and more on the large side.
So one can think about if
there's more products over
reactants, that's going to
indicate something about the
delta g nought for the reaction,
and the k -- the k,
if it's greater than 1, if it's
a big number, then there
are more products than
reactants, and delta g nought
would be negative and would
tend to be a large number.
All right, so this is more
actually kind of simple
bookkeeping involved that
if you know steps in the
reactions and you know
equilibrium constants, you can
calculate an overall
equilibrium
constant for that reaction.
So you can write a reaction
as the sum of different
components.
And so up here, we are going to
try to add these first two
equations to get this
net equation.
So we have 2 gas p 3 c l 2 going
to 2 p l c 3, and that's
equilibrium 1.
And so then in the next
reaction, some of that is
being consumed reacting with
another c l 2, giving you p c
l 5, and the net reaction we're
interested in has 2 p 5
c l 2's going to 2 p c l 5.
All right, what do I have to
do before I can add these
together effectively and
have things cancel out?
I need to multiply what?
Second equation by 2, yeah.
So to get that to work I would
need to have 2's there, then
this is going to cancel out and
these will add up, so we
have 5 and then we have two
of the main products.
So if I do that, and I have the
equilibrium constant for
one and for two, how am I
going to get equilibrium
constant for three?
I'm going to multiply
k 1 by k 2 and k 2.
So I'm going to have to multiply
k 2 in there twice,
because there's two of those
-- we'd multiply that up.
So if you have different parts
of reactions and you can sum
them together, then you can
multiply out the individual
k's to get the new value of k.
So that's something that's just
useful that you'll run
into in doing these
types of problems.
All right.
Now we're going to
think about how
equilibriums respond to stress.
And I always feel like
I need to pause.
MIT students, you guys are some
of the smartest, most
talented scientists
in the world.
I don't know if you fully
appreciate how
smart you all are.
But this concept is tough
for MIT students.
So Le Chatelier's principle
says that a system in
equilibrium that is subjected to
with stress tends to react
in such a way to minimize
that stress.
I have advisees coming to
my office saying, "I'm
double-majoring in this and
that and I'm taking five
classes and I have UROP and I
have this lab exercise --
I don't know what's going on,
so I've been thinking a lot
about it and I think I should
add a third major." Le
Chatelier would be very
unhappy with that.
Le Chatelier would say that the
appropriate response is to
drop one of the majors, to
minimize the stress.
So in doing these problems, what
I want to encourage you
to do is think the opposite
of what you would do.
Minimize the stress.
If you think about that
you'll be all set.
All right.
So Le Chatelier's principle
actually is very useful.
If you think about minimizing
the stress, you'll be able to
predict the direction that
the reaction will shift.
So the reaction's going to shift
in a way to minimize the
stress, so you can predict it.
If you're thinking along these
lines, you say, oh, that
system was stressed, and then
you can think about how that
reaction or that system
is going to respond.
So let's give some examples.
So, we have a system in
equilibrium -- we started out,
we had our nitrogen
and our hydrogen
and we had no product.
We reacted the hydrogen and the
nitrogen, their forming
products, and eventually they
reach equilibrium, their delta
g equals zero there's still
the reaction going on, but
there's no net change.
All right, now the system
is going to be stressed.
So we're going to add
more of a reactant.
How will the system react
to minimize that stress?
What is it going to do?
It now has too much of
one of the reactants.
You'll form more products, and
that's going to use up some of
your other reactant, which will
go down, and you're going
to form more product until
equilibrium is reached again.
And one thing that I'll mention
that the ratio has to
be the same.
The equilibrium constant is
a constant given the same
temperature, but you're not
necessarily always going to
have the same concentrations,
but you should have the same
ratios, the same value of k.
All right, so what about if you
add more product, what's
going to happen?
What direction will the
reaction shift?
Right, it's going to shift
toward the reactants, so
you're going to make more of
each of the two reactants
until again, you find your
equilibrium again.
And then the reaction's still
going but there's no net
change anymore.
All right, so let's think about
this -- let's think
about this in terms of
the math as well.
If you want to stick with the
math, that's OK, you can think
about calculating
delta g's here.
So if you're a system in
equilibrium and you add more
hydrogen, the system
will respond to
minimize that increase.
So it's going to make more
product that will minimize the
increase, it shifts
to the right.
And this can be explained
in terms of q and k.
So, you can think about,
again, do you have more
products now or did you have
more products at equilibrium,
and if you're adding more
reactants, momentarily q will
become less than k.
And so, you would get a negative
delta g, which would
make it spontaneous in the
forward direction.
So some people like to think
about this in terms of delta g
equals r t natural
log of q over k.
So you think about if q is less
than k, what sign you
have for delta g, and that's
tells you whether the reaction
is spontaneous in the forward
or the reverse direction.
And let me just give you
one hint for taking
exams in this unit.
That use of the arrow is really
good, or saying "toward
product" or "reactant." I can't
tell you how many people
write -- know what the answer
is and write left when mean
right, or write right
when they mean left.
But if you draw an arrow you
never really get it wrong, and
when you say products or
reactants it's a lot harder to
make that mistake.
So if you're not good with right
or left, which let me
tell you a large fraction of
people are not, hedge your
bets, you can write everything,
more products,
arrows, and then write if you
want, then you're pretty sure
that you have it all in there.
OK.
So again, we can explain this
in terms of q or k.
All right.
So let's just quickly talk about
adding more products.
We did this already.
If more products are added. then
q is going to be greater
than k momentarily, and you
would shift toward reactants,
shift toward the left, and
again, we saw that down there.
So tell me a final clicker
question and then we're done.
What happens if you remove
products and why?
OK, 10 seconds.
See if we can get in the 90's.
No, no 90's today, we'll have
to do it next time,
but we got 73 right.
So we're going to make more
products as well.